good evening from Miami in Florida I've
just finished a remarkable interview
with tennis icon Martina Navratilova
that had double cancer diagnosis so I
was in a total panic for three days
thinking I may not see next Christmas
throat cancer and breast cancer who has
two cancers at the same time I was never
an underachiever but this is getting
ridiculous we sat down just days after
she completed her final course of
chemotherapy she got that Bell which
said that it's all over at least for now
to go through it and then to watch it
back and to feel that and I can see you
know so when you're going through it you
you have tears of feeling sorry for
yourself this tear was just happiness
and she talked about the remarkable
support she's had from the tennis
community especially Chris Evan who
herself battled cancer you were both
treated in the same time you can't make
it up yeah your great rival the
parallels are unbelievable and at the
end I was joined by her beautiful wife
Julia would you say all those same
things about Julio
it took me a little bit my heart's
broken
what do you think of that why not scuba
diving my scuba diving I'm scared of
sharks and the plans they've had to
leave behind we were waiting for Funko
to
welcome a child home and then we were
fighting to Kansas so here is my world
exclusive interview with Martin and
rattle over as she said she 'd head over
fighter
Martinez it's great to see you nice to
see you how are you
um well you know what makes what chemo
does to you is you feel so horrible that
after you start recovering you you feel
better every single day but you still
feel like crap so that's when we realize
how many levels of crap there are until
you start feeling semi-normal so I'm
semi-normal now but the leftovers are
still there it's been I mean a very
unpleasant experience for you it's not
your first time that you've had to go
through
a battle with cancer
how has it been different if it has this
time well uh so the first time it
happened was 13 years ago and it was
dcis doctorma Institute which means it
could turn into cancer but it's kind of
pre-cancerous situation but you still
have to do the radiation Etc so it was a
shock to the system but compared to when
I got this diagnosis that was piece of
cake that was like a non-issue because
this one at first when the doctor told
me uh that I had cancer squamous
squamous cell carcinoma uh in the throat
and then he says and by the way we don't
know where it's coming from we need to
find out it could be the lungs or the
liver or the kidneys
end of story so I'm this is Friday
afternoon when I got the news had you
gone in for a routine check no no so
have we found it uh when I had um uh I
noticed that my left lymph node was
enlarged and I thought it was from a
shingles shot that I just had vaccine
like week before and I thought it was
maybe from that but then a couple weeks
when it didn't go down I called the
doctor and he ordered a biopsy were you
feeling after a couple of weeks were you
feeling a sense of foreboding about it
it wasn't going down oh well I since
before bunny when I asked the doctor
what do you think the chances are he
says what 50 50 I'm like I don't like
those odds so that's when I thought
because the lymph nodes don't get
swelled up for no reason
um and uh that so I didn't have a good
feeling about it at that point so I'm
thinking it could be the brain it could
be the pancreas labor is not a good
thing either neither is lives so I was
in a total panic for three days thinking
I may not see next Christmas wow so I
had three horrible nights I'm like he
needed to find doubt so Monday Monday
morning I'll speak to an oncologist and
he says oh it's for sure coming from
from the throat and it's p16 which is
extremely treatable and in 95 full
recovery so we
big big relief but you know so
emotionally it's been up and down
because uh because of what the doctor
initially told me the initial when you
first had the test yes what was the
first cancer detected the breast cancer
or throat cancer no the throat cancer it
was the first thing yeah so what they do
they know it's cancer they know it's in
the throat but they don't know where so
then you do a PET scan
and um and what you don't eat uh and
then they give you glucose and then the
Cancer Sucks the glucose so that's where
they know where the cancer is so that's
when they see exactly where it is in the
throat and my right breast lit up as
well
so literally literally well the the
cancer lights up it's it goes It goes
red and this was the other breast to the
one that you yeah you had the first one
was on the left uh lumpectomy and took
out some lymph nodes and the right one
uh is different cancer of some similar
area uh but this was a real actual real
tumor that was about seven eight
millimeters so they caught it so early
that they did not see it on the uh on on
the mammogram which I just had I mean
Europe so you're a famously tough
athlete you don't get to win 59 Grand
Slam titles without being a tough cookie
and you'd been through an earlier bout
of cancer but even for you
with your mentality to be told you've
got throat cancer and breast cancer and
it's in the other breast to the one that
you had treated last time yeah that is a
massive
moment yeah it was because again very up
and down right so I find out it's the
throat cancer of think up could be dying
but I find out no it's very treatable
then they found the right right breast
uh and when I had the uh the biopsy on
the right breast the the doctor was
saying this doesn't look great
um and that's when she said that I'm
like oh great I have another cancer
that's when I started crying on the
table as she's still poking in there
getting samples out of my boob I'm like
oh great I have two cancers at the same
time that I'm not related under that no
connection at all who does that who has
two cancers at the same time I'm like I
was never an underachiever but this is
getting ridiculous
following in Chris ever's footsteps who
went through cancer a year before we
ended up being in the same place in New
York's lawn catering I'm like you were
both treated you can't make it up it
just got me yeah you're a great rival
the parallels are unbelievable with the
two that's extraordinary really because
she had ovarian cancer at the start of
2022 right and so you both end up being
treated in the same place same place
same people some of the same same nurses
that were you know giving me uh sis
platin she was getting some other
chemotherapy drug but same place we rang
the same Bell and uh that's amazing yeah
I mean and you know I mean she grew up
in four other Leona lives in Boca I live
in Miami we both had a place in Aspen of
course the careers are are always
intertwined and then we follow each
other this way and she she made it she
was on Saturday Night Live years ago
when she retired and did a skit about
how competitive we were
and I'm like this is the kind of
competition we don't really want but I
must say Chris has been just a stalwart
she has uh supported me so much through
this as I supported her a year ago a
little little did I know that it was
going to be reciprocated in this manner
but uh she's been great
the moment you know you have both
cancers you see you've got very
emotional but is that a moment you know
people talk about the life flashing
before them you you said the first time
this happened to you that because you
were so young and so healthy you were
very positive and came through it it's
probably a bit tougher when you're in
your mid-60s exactly did you did you
think my God this this I mean this could
be it yeah I did you definitely come
face to face with your mortality a lot
more when you're 65 than when you're 50
or 55 or whatever I was 52. so that was
um and you know the bucket list comes
into mind with all the things that I
want to do and this may sound really
shallow but this came into my Minds like
okay which Kick-Ass car do I really want
to drive if I only have like a year see
you already thinking that's what I was
thinking about yeah you might you might
only have a year I totally thought that
uh when I again when I didn't know where
it was coming from that that's a
definite possibility once that oncology
said no it's from your throat and it's
very treatable then I'm like okay so
what do we do so you get into the as a
tennis player you have to be in that
solution you have to be in game mode and
so that's where I think being a champion
athlete comes in pretty handy one of the
I mean amazing irony is about this I
guess is that after your first bout the
cancer you then spent the next few years
telling when we get checked get checked
because the first time it had been I
think a four-year Gap from your last
exactly mammogram mammogram and so you
were determined right that other women
didn't fall into that trap of being a
bit lazy about it and actually it
probably helped you get action quicker
than you may have done oh you're
absolutely right it's probably nothing
but you better find out because if it is
something then you wanted to catch it as
early as possible so being diligent
definitely helps and as an athlete when
you have an injury you take care of it
right away you don't wait for it to get
better you tweeted uh this double whammy
is serious but fixable I'm hoping for a
favorable outcome it's going to stink
for a while yeah but I'll fight with all
I have got
what were you feeling as you wrote those
words oh I I knew it was going to be
hard but I didn't realize it was going
to be as hard as it really was
um you know I love to eat as you know we
have had dinner together I love to eat
and uh eating was the hardest part of
this whole treatment I lost 15 pounds
not because I wanted to but because I
just couldn't get enough food in in my
in my in my body uh the the radiation
the proton therapy affects your throat
and and the mouth and there's a lot
going on and it started closing I
couldn't even yawn you try to you start
yawning and it closes up and it stops
the yawn halfway I couldn't sneeze it
was like because it was so swollen and I
only had three weeks of the proton when
the normal course is seven weeks but
thankfully at Sloan catering Dr Nancy
Lee started this program where you only
do three three three weeks even if it
resolves then you stop if it doesn't
then you do the seven and you had to
wear this extraordinary mask I'm gonna
bring in exhibit one oh yeah
um
reunite you with your mask I call her
Lucille
come on Lucille here we go
yeah so explain what this is and why you
had to use this
so they you see all these holes that's
how they tape it you lay you're laying
on a table and even for the back of the
head you have a formed a cushion that's
yours and then and then put this on top
and they they fat they they uh tape it
down with these little pegs so you
literally cannot even open your eyes
maybe a little bit I could see out of my
right eye but most of the time I
couldn't just can't move you cannot move
because the proton is so specific uh
ready to radiate from four different
angles so yeah why did you call it
Lucille oh so a very good friend of mine
had had a Harley I sold her my Harley
and she named the Harley Lucille and she
was a really close friend and she died
from cancer
Lucille but Lucio's gonna get smashed
I mean like smash not drunk but probably
broken into a thousand pieces you learn
to hate Lucille some people make a
planter out of them but I think I'll
just smash the heck whatever
you also had chemotherapy yeah at the
same time so were they happening
concurrently or did you have to break it
up yeah it was at the same time so chemo
was week one week four week seven of the
proton and proton was every single day
for seven weeks and that was the hard
part because the first week is both
chemo and radiation at the same time and
when you start feeling lousy you're not
sure if it's from the chemo or the
proton proton is much more gradual uh
then the effects on the throat are more
gradual so you just hit from all the
ends and I don't think the doctors do a
very good job of telling you what how
it's gonna really hit the fan you know
they tell you well this could happen or
that could happen but it's a oh
everybody's different but they don't
really get you ready for help or
anything like this no
the toughest thing you've had it's
definitely the toughest thing I've ever
done uh yeah I mean it still is hard I
still don't feel great but I feel better
every day off the break more from my
exclusive interview with Martin in that
rattle over
[Music]
how do you feel emotional
emotionally has been really weird so the
emotional part was more difficult before
I started the treatment because I still
didn't know if they were going to accept
me into the program when the breast
cancer showed up I didn't know if that
was going to disqualify me because I
knew the seven weeks was going to be
brutal this is a trial thing the trial
that's hopefully three weeks instead of
seven and I knew that would be a massive
difference in long term no not forget
the seven weeks you're doing it it's
when when you do it the seven weeks and
depending on how big the tumor is it
could affect you the rest of your life
so the biggest stress was getting into
the treatment uh which finally did
happen so emotionally very up and down
beforehand once the treatment started
the harder part was physical getting
through that and of course that plays on
your emotions too so I did a bit of
crying overall probably maybe a grand
total of 15 minutes but uh you know it
just kind of hits you and then you're
like okay you just have to suck it up
and there's always somebody that's worse
off than you are especially when you see
kids around there well that's what's
going to ask I mean
there were children young kids
around you yeah having treatment which
may or may not save their lives right
what was that like to to see on a daily
basis reality check reality check I mean
you know everybody that's there has
cancer you just don't know which one so
cancer is a is a is very uh Democratic
it totally doesn't care who you are
we're all kind of in the same boat but
different boats because some may they
don't know if they're going to be cured
I know my chances were pretty good but
when you see kids that's when you really
stop feeling sorry for yourself because
the parents go through the kids may not
even know what they're going through
there were kids that were six eight
months old
toddlers children you know newborns
practically and they have to put them to
sleep to do the treatment so they don't
move
um that's when it like you just don't
feel sorry for yourself anymore it's
okay you just gotta suck it up and deal
with it
you had an amazing moment this was um
a little video of you
the Bell being run just thinking about
the end of your treatment I'll just let
you watch it
[Music]
[Applause]
it was hard not to cry I tell you I'm
crying just looking at it again
because you wait you wait you just can't
wait to ring the bell
um and uh
you know it's still in God's hands so to
speak whether you're gonna be 100 or not
but uh you hope for the best
yeah I'm gonna lose you
[Music]
the people were great they were really
phenomenal
it's it's a I mean it was wonderfully
moving to watch that yeah for me I can't
even imagine for you
to go through it and then to watch it
back and to feel that and I can see yeah
because you have you have you know so
when when you're going through the
treatments you have some feeling sorry
for yourself three uh tears you they you
pick your music what do you want to
listen to so usually it was Bob Marley
which was great it was the best music I
didn't listen to one time I picked Elton
John and then he starts singing I'm
still standing and I'm like he he sang
that to me in Paris uh during the French
Open in the 80s went to his concert and
I dedicated this song to Martina I'm
still standing because he knew that was
one of my favorites so when they're you
know I'm in this freaking masks uh not
not able to move and that song came on
I'm like oh great so I can't really cry
because I can swallow I can't move
uh so you you have tears of feeling
sorry for yourself this tear was just
happiness at the end because you've been
waiting for seven damn weeks
and um yeah I mean the the work is not
finished but the worst part is behind me
and now and we know I will just keep
feeling better every day what have they
told you about the prognosis going
forward now uh it's very very good I
mean as far as they know I'm cancer-free
I still need to deal with the right
breast uh probably will have radiation
but that's a couple weeks and it's like
that doesn't even count
and uh that's more pre preventative than
anything else and um you know should be
should be good to go it's like 99
um uh solo solvable
um so I definitely will not be missing
any of my checkups I'll be very diligent
about it but the prognosis is excellent
um but you never know just like it you
know you never know you mentioned music
and your age of Mary had this wonderful
idea of getting a lot of your friends
from the tennis world
send a song to Rally your spirits and
they all sent songs with messages and I
want to just go through some of these I
found it really moving actually it was
amazing um Chris Evert we talked about
it obviously had just had cancer herself
treated I didn't know at the same Clinic
as your great rival and she sent you
Lean On Me by Bill Withers which
includes the line I just might have a
problem that you'll understand we all
need someone to lean on Lean on Me When
You're Not Strong and I'll be your
friend I'll help you carry on yeah
you're making me cry again
I couldn't even read the stuff when Mary
first sent it to me I just started
crying and I'm crying now God I'm such a
softy
um
and I I started reading and I'm like I
cannot listen to the music because I'll
definitely be bawling my eyes out so I
just kind of one day at a time I read a
little bit from what everybody wrote
because it was so moving Lindsay
Davenport what she said Sam Smith Claire
balding uh Chrissy Claire building sent
you something inside so strong yeah like
lady suffering uh something is so strong
I know that I can make it Billie Jean
King sent you I Will Survive by Gloria
yeah thanks a lot for that
that's a happy song uh but yeah it was
yeah just uh both sides now by Joni
Mitchell which had the lyrics I've
looked at live from both sides now from
win and lose and still somehow it's live
Solutions I recall I really don't know
life at all yeah and Sue Barker just I
Believe In You by Il Divo I I know
that's like I mean it's total teal
jerkers all of them and uh and then what
they said to me personally outside of
the song was just so meaningful
um that I had to like parse it to myself
a little bit at a time because it was so
overwhelming and you don't realize how
much you mean to people until they do
something like that and you know that's
that's really special so the tennis
world has been amazing uh the support
that I've gotten I hear even Jimmy
Connors said Jimmy's called me actually
Jimmy called I mean the greatest Street
Fighter in tennis history after you
right what did he say to you Jimmy
um just he was that I was gonna kick
Cancer's but see I got I got my little
bracelet here I got I got my so I bought
myself the Julia gave me this one
Cartier
this one I bought from myself tough as
nails when I finished treatment that's
what I put it on his nails tough as
nails and then I have cancer which is
from a friend who passed away a couple
of years ago but she was she had a great
life and and Jimmy says I know you're
gonna you know win this battle so yeah
when you get that kind of support like
yeah I'm gonna kick the tire did you
actually because of the music choices
did you did you play the songs
I play them eventually but it took me a
while it took me I was delighted to I
mean I suppose I'm in I don't want a
single one out but because because of
what Chris Eva had been through herself
so recently because you've been such
great Rivals because you've been treated
at the same place yeah I just felt her
choice of lean on me yeah because you
had been right there for her I remember
reading your your tweets to Chris ever
at the time and then suddenly you're in
this world of pain
physically emotionally else and she's
there saying Lean on Me well Chris gave
me this little necklace and I was
wearing it for a while then I you know
took it off and replaced it and when
Chris got sick as I put it back on I'm
like I'm not gonna take this off until
she gets well
so I never took it off I finally had to
take it off to put the mask on
to get the radiation I had to take this
off so I finally put it back on again
today
uh I mean uh we we you know what even
with arrivals we still depended on each
other
we met each other better and I think we
met each other better humans as well I
mean we were always there for each other
no matter what that's an amazing thing I
mean just for me is a a great tennis fan
who watched you guys go at it for all
those years the fact that when it really
mattered actually it wasn't a sport this
was life and death yeah there you are
again yeah
but this time United together yes oh and
I guess we'll we'll go into the sunset
together maybe hopefully when we're
about 100 years old a lot of tennis
players live to be a hundred so I'm
still planning on that but we'll see but
this is a definite big hiccup but yeah
if you look at the hall of famers or or
people that really play tennis tennis
has been found to be the one sport that
prolongs your life more than any other
activity was there anything that Chris I
mean the opening line of lean on me I
just might have a problem you'll
understand was there anything in
particular given what she'd just been
through which really helped you
um the mental toughness of course
um I mean hers was more of a question
whether she was going to be okay I think
hers was more dangerous oh
solution wise
and and also she won I think she had six
sessions of it was just really beat her
up where it beat her up so much that she
couldn't even reply and that's that's
when I knew it was really really tough
and I knew that she what she went
through that that I could ask her a
question I would get an honest answer
and uh so we mostly texted but we also
spoke a couple times and um
it was just so different if she hadn't
gone through it it would have been a
different situation did it help you do
you think it definitely helped uh every
little bit helps you don't know what
puts you on the over the edge right just
just like you don't know what when
cancer happens what makes it click the
wrong way just like you don't know what
makes it click the right way when you
when you uh when you are healing when
you are trying to kill it uh and so
every little bit helps all that positive
energy so that's why it's so essential
to surround yourself with people that
give you that energy that when you have
these great Champions Chris uh Billie
Jean and others
is there something about being a great
sporting Champion which gives you that
little extra reservoir of strength and
you've so often been you know trailing
in a massive final at Wimbledon you've
got to somehow dig deeper perhaps more
than most people do does that trait help
when you're finding something absolutely
I I know Chris never gave up playing
when she was playing I mean Billie Jean
by her own uh account had tanked a few
matches where she you know just screw it
I'm not I'm not I'm not doing it anymore
but Chris and I I don't I don't ever
recall I mean I felt sorry for myself
thinking okay I'm probably gonna lose
but I'm just gonna keep fighting until
the match point is over
um and the tennis teaches you that I
think and maybe Champions have that more
than the you know player rank 200 or
maybe they just can't be any better even
though they're giving everything they
have but you definitely have that
mentality that I am not quitting until
the match point is finished and
um you're always in the solution so that
tennis teaches you that and and um that
mentality that Chris and I I don't know
if you're born with it or if you learn
it later but you definitely it's a it
becomes a habit are you planning a long
drunken lunch you two we
alcohol it tastes terrible
terrible the alcohol for two months
during the treatment I quit I didn't
want to but then the taste buds change
and I taste a little tequila the other
day oh my God wine horrible it's like
the worst vinegar
it will come back it's coming back
slowly but uh I I never been drunk in my
life but I may get drunk this time I
don't know this would be a good time to
celebrate I think so we're definitely
getting together to see a few of you
ladies having a long lunch we might do
something maybe
part is legal here in Florida so maybe
we'll just smoke a joint in honor of Bob
Marley and uh and not get drunk so but
definitely will be a lot of laughs
uh well they just played all Bob Marley
but uh Could You Be Loved is my favorite
yeah
your father you said used to say if it
doesn't involve your health it's not
worth poop it's so true you said then
this was after your first battle of
cancer because when I was diagnosed the
whole world stopped for me everything
else became irrelevant having been
through that once
was it more pronounced this time that
period you said of three days where you
just didn't know and your mind is
spiraling into all sorts of Dark Places
you know even for someone like you has
got that mental strength how hard was
that uh it it was it was rough those
three days oh I can't ever have them
back those were the hardest three days
all your plans basically it's everything
stops everything stops everything
stopped 13 years ago and it really
stopped this time around because it was
so much more complex even when I found
out that it wasn't as bad as it could
have been it's still you know then then
the second cancer shows up a week later
I'm like oh my God uh what am I gonna do
so
um yeah your priorities really do
realign completely and and then if you
get through it then you really I really
only want to be doing things that I want
to do rather than things that other
people want to do more after the break
from Martinez
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored from Miami in
Florida what are your number one
priorities now what are the things you
think right staying healthy
um taking care of myself taking care of
my wife taking care of the kids
well kids that's 21 and 17 but you know
there's two kids well these are your
your two daughters obviously
um Julia's girls and there you you call
them your daughters well they are I mean
I raised them there was six and a half
and two and a half when we got together
15 years ago so yeah very tough for them
and they're great and they they were
they were thrown for a loop
um yeah
um they both said I don't know how to
process this uh especially when we
weren't really sure exactly what was
going on
um and Julia was white as why does these
curtains so when we first found out she
was she was scared I think she was maybe
scared more than I was
um because it's always harder for the
people that survive you right uh but uh
it was terrifying forever because
everyone's lives are on hold right very
much so uh and once you get in the
solution then you can kind of get on
with it and Victoria came uh twice to be
with me uh during the treatment Julia
was there at the beginning and at the
end middle I kind of kept to myself and
and there was one thing that was with me
all the time that was Lulu I think we're
gonna bring Lulu on before before the
end my dog my little ducks went
um so but it's it's still a lonely
battle but uh it's important to surround
yourself with people that support you
and and the family my family was there
for me there was a lovely moment that
Julia decided to surprise you by cutting
your hair back to the kind of Parisian
bulb she had when you first met her and
fell in love because he'd always said
how much you love that style that's true
and she was planning this whole surprise
she wasn't going to FaceTime you so you
saw it she was going to just basically
turn up yeah and you said did she manage
to keep it a seat she did she did and
she's terrible at keeping secrets like
she never buys presents ahead of time
because she wants to give them to you
like today she didn't want to wait till
a month from now so she she kept her
bargain and uh I just uh I was like
laughing like crazy because uh brought
back really good memories when we first
got together when did you first see it
with the new stuff uh in New York yeah
when she came to when she came to see me
the last week of which was the hardest
week was the last chemo of what the also
the doctors don't tell you is that chemo
is cumulative so Julia was there for me
uh when it was the worst uh worst batch
but uh she looked so cute she looks
younger and she looks great now of
course I got my hair cut too because I
though this chemo doesn't make you lose
your hair I was kind of hoping actually
that I would lose the hair because
usually it grows back thicker Chris's
hair is thicker she loves her she had
different chemo and uh her hair is
really cute short but really thick I'm
like why couldn't so see the competition
comes in again now Chris has thicker
hair than me I'm kidding you've been
married since 2014. how important has
she been this year four years massive
massive I mean uh yeah Julia didn't do
deal with the first cancer that well of
course it wasn't a serious but she was
like trying to run away from it running
away from it
um but uh this time around she was there
all the way holding my hand when I
needed to be held and uh and they're
physically and of course emotionally all
the times it's a bit of a cliche people
say these things they can make you
as she calls distance between people in
the situation or he can bring you closer
together yeah what do you feel like I
did that it brings it brought us closer
together the first one there was some
distance this one brought us close
together and this is the one that was
really much much tougher much more
severe and uh serious and uh yeah we're
closer definitely she said that you were
talking about adopting a child because
the two girls have now got to the age
where they've yeah they've left time
empty their syndrome how far have you
got with that and has this changed
anything uh I think so well we hired an
agency
um
uh Julia was devastated when Emma went
to live in Europe uh for the last two
years in high school and the emptiness
really hit her I'm like go go she was
like no come back
uh so yeah I think it was uh it was a
nice thought for a while but I think
this kind of brought it into
sharp Focus you know I'm not the
youngest anymore and I don't want to be
the grandma on the uh on the playground
but forget that part it's just uh
there's just not enough space I think
for for this to happen uh so we were
thinking about adopting but that's
definitely put on hold and I don't think
it's gonna happen do you know I I don't
I think it's just too complicated and uh
you know the energy you know they only
have so much uh right would you be sad
about that yeah of course uh it was uh
it was a nice idea a nice thought nice
possibility but yeah I gotta be a little
more realistic so uh I mean Julia will
will support whatever uh whatever but
yeah it's just I think there's just only
so much you can do in your in your with
your energy and I don't think it's there
for me
you made a powerful speech quite
recently actually talking about cancer
you were telling people we're not here
forever don't keep things on the back
burner are you pursuing passion cancer
dared me to be brave to be inspirational
to be humbled and to be calm and that
was after your first experience
what's it daring you to be now do you
think obviously changed some big
priorities but yeah what do you feel is
daring you to be now
well I think I'm still still kind of
dealing with the after effects like my
mouth right now is really dry I'm still
not tasting things eating is still
really hard me who loves to eat uh I'm
missing all these meals great diet plan
though
wouldn't wouldn't we should have my
worst enemy so I'm still dealing with
recovery
but overall
I think just really seize those days you
know you're not gonna let you know you
can't ever have them back again and I
don't want to waste
um I don't want to waste my energy on
things that are not productive that are
not meaningful they don't feel your soul
and they don't make a difference for not
just me but people around and maybe the
World At Large what kind of things in
our life I'm not doing that anymore
um
things that you've guilted into
what for some charity or for some person
whatever
uh no
you know I'd rather go to dinner with
four dear friends and have a great meal
and have a great exchange of ideas you
said that last time you had a private
pity party but it didn't last very long
did you have a private pity party what
well private yes pity more like really I
mean two cancers at the same time again
who the hell does that so I I had a pity
party but uh again you know being the
the tennis player that I was who used to
be or somebody who has been uh some
people said oh yeah but I'm a good
husband
um
it's getting in a solution so you just
stay in that and you have those moments
but again they're short-lived uh you
know and sometimes it hits me without
even thinking yesterday I was watching
TV and I was all of a sudden I started
crying like everyone I really didn't
deserve that you know what did I do to
deserve that uh but again it's just a
random thought yeah but again lasts
about 30 seconds and then you're like
I'm so lucky because it could have been
so much worse this cancer 20 years ago
would have been life-changing they they
cut they didn't have proton and they
would the surgery they literally like
saw your jaw open to get to the throat
now they do robotic surgery so it's much
much easier
so I was lucky with as bad as it was I
still got lucky I will have full
recovery what's on the Martina bucket
list now oh Galapagos that's been on
that for forever why are you so Keen
together well just to see all the life
all that life I just want to swim I'm on
a snorkel I want to scuba dive and see
all these seals and and tortoises and
sharks and you know all these creatures
uh Team it's teaming with Wildlife uh
and I love Wildlife I spent six months
in Kenya I love it there I want to go
back to Kenya again I really feel at
home there when you were going through
the most difficult part of this
did you have that kind of throwback at
your life did you look at your life yeah
and what did you feel about your life to
that moment
I could have done more but I also could
have done less
um and overall what a life I've had how
lucky am I I'm not planning on leaving
it anytime soon no damn right damn right
did you have any big regrets when you
were thinking I've only got a year to
live I wish I'd done that or uh well
then I would try to figure out what to
pack into it if it really if it was
finite or then I would really put the
priorities there
um but you know I love my work I can't
wait to start working uh I'm working on
the tennis channel uh for the tournament
uh in Miami this next two weeks and I
can't wait to see everybody I love my
work I mean it seems to me just having
no knew a little bit but you've LED an
extraordinary successful life but a very
tough one too I mean you've had to come
through personally and professionally
but personally a lot of big challenges
but the the common theme is you've
always come through them yeah do you
feel like at your core is just a fighter
what was the alternative giving up
giving in stopping that's just not an
option for me so uh yeah you get on with
it I think growing up in the communist
country you're tough you have to be and
you're kind of stoic because you can't
feel sorry for yourself because you
would just be crying all the time
because you don't have any freedom
so
um you know I grabbed that chance when I
got it and I was never gonna look back
so no regrets the only regret I have is
that I had to do it but I really to
pursue my dream which was to play tennis
and be free uh I had to leave my country
and and I can't ever have those years
back with my family and I hurt them so
that was tough but uh regrets I wish I
had gotten a coach earlier I would have
won more probably would have stopped
sooner as well so yeah whatever it is
it's a wash but uh
um quitting is just not in my DNA
that I think is completely true yeah
after the break
[Music]
and here's the final part of my
interview with marcena where we're
joined by her wife Julia
well I'll be joined by two more ladies
uh Julia your lovely wife and by Lulu
Lulu
She's Always a Lady she is always
incredibly well-made Lulu was with me
through every treatment in fact I
smuggled her to the hospital because I
didn't know they were allowed dogs I
didn't want to ask in case they say no
so she was Contraband and then during
one of those treatments she poked her
nose through the through the doggy bag
and the nurse says oh what a cute dog so
that's when I knew dogs were okay
and um you've actually picked up that
you were going through something well
she's she's always following me around
so I don't know not sure because she's
always like attached to my left hip so
you found it very comforting to have
Lulu she is she's great she uh she
doesn't argue and she follows me
everywhere and she's very well
housebroken so not a problem at all she
can she can hold her her pee for a long
time would you say all those same things
about Julia or Julius it took me a
little bit my heart's broken a little
bit longer to train Julia but
she's very supportive uh amazing amazing
she's been there for me Julia what's it
been like for you because you've been
married since 2014 so nearly 10 years
now and you know these are the love of
each other's lives and suddenly Martina
gets hit with a double blow throat
cancer and a breast cancer it's
obviously potentially incredibly serious
life-changing potentially life ending
what was it like for you she said that
the first time she had a wrong with
cancer you were slightly distant from it
you didn't really want to get that yeah
I was at this time you went completely
the opposite way
well when your wife is diagnosed with
cancer and especially two cancers it
puts life in perspectives
um
the values and everything just what
seems to be important suddenly not that
important and the other way around
um it changes your perspective and look
at life
and really makes you think what's what's
what's important who is the most
important person for you in your life
and what do they need and of course they
need support and Martina needed me it
was about Martina not about myself
the way to comfort her make sure
she's okay she's all right and do things
I usually wouldn't do you know like cook
it's usually like you know but you're
okay
be like nag less and do things for
Martina because I'm so used to Martina
doing a lot of things to comfort me what
was the hardest moment for you this
whole thing
when my
was found out that she had cancer but
she had to wait like four days so five
days before she knew where and what it
was for me it was really hard because
you know what you say to somebody oh
it's going to be all right darling but
then you may be lying maybe it's not
gonna be all right so you don't know and
I am Martina knows me more like as a
hardcore person I don't easily cry but
she doesn't know that I do cry like
behind the closed doors but for me it
was like really difficult to hold my
tears and not show her in her face what
I was like really feeling and thinking
there was a look in Julia's face that I
never saw before
because she was scared yeah we were both
scared but um
yeah she didn't
that was there was just a different look
and body language that I haven't seen
before Martina said she felt this had
actually brought you closer together
this whole experience very much so yes
the you know my empty nesting syndrome
disappeared you know happy girls are
gone and having their life and
looking out for each other themselves
and also for us and we kind of rebonded
reconnected and revalued
re-evaluation of values happen and
importance and what we want to do and
what's on the bucket list and where we
want to go on her bucket list is the
Galapagos Islands I'm sure
I guess that yeah I mean I'm seeing it
kind of maybe a renewal of marriage vows
in the Galactica because what do you
think of that why not scuba diving why
scuba diving I'm scared of sharks yeah
she likes all the stuff you don't like
she like all the stuff she's like
normally yeah I'll do a lot for love but
maybe not scuba diving so what do you
think I'm seeing a scene in the
galavagus with maybe a blue whale in the
background
actually sometimes these kind of things
they do make people want to renew
wedding vows do you think it's something
you might do
sure
it's like we're renewing them almost
every day yeah
but you do like but you do like symbolic
things and love symbolic things
exactly maybe next year but then you
were supposed to tell me that it's
supposed to be something
like now I already know to change
destination with respect she proposed to
you last time she did
live on TV I think you owe one yeah
thank you pierce
let's do something yeah but now you just
spill the beans
we can pretend it's a surprise
one of the things that probably won't
happen now is you probably won't adopt a
child as a consequence of all this
surprises you don't know whatever what's
happening right like we were waiting for
phone call to
welcome a child home and then we were
fighting to Kansas so today it is not
the first thing I'm thinking about
because the first thing I'm thinking
about is for matina to get well and
better and stronger
and we'll see what happens you know I
personally did not put it on
a complete like
postponed for like no it's not a no for
me but I don't know I literally don't
know we don't know it's possible but not
like possible we don't know life is full
of surprises like who knows
the one thing that isn't surprising is
how tough she is she's very tough what's
the alternative though she's very tough
right she's very tough it's easy to be
brave when you have no other option
right
right I mean that is my view of life
right if you get hit with a thing let's
see what else are you gonna do yeah roll
over exactly but it's still you know
you've got to do it you've got to do it
and I have a completely different
perspective of life now because before I
would postpone it for tomorrow for
tomorrow for later for later for later I
was like this perfect you know Scarlett
O'Hara okay like tomorrow not anymore I
feel young super young now you know why
you got the young haircut well that's
another story but I told the story yeah
I feel young now because tomorrow I'll
be a day older right so that's it I'm
young now and I want to do things that I
can and I have energy for
um huge humongous Appetite For Life are
you proud of the way she's so
proud
so proud
um
amazed how like strong she was during
this I'm a total hypochondriac I'm
scared of everything and everything you
know and any medical procedure anything
I cry a little bit everything I just
always imagine the voice and matina she
handled it so with such strengths and
positivity I literally don't know how
she managed to
hold it all together what did you think
of all the tennis people sending their
favorite song to inspire her I think
it's so sweet I did not send the song
you didn't
it's herself icing I wish I wish I
cannot make a sound she's beautiful but
she cannot sing so but when she does
makes me laugh when I sing it makes you
laugh when did you hear me sing you
never heard me yeah well when when you
don't know I'm around
[Laughter]
I don't want to intrude into something
here I'm sure it wasn't one of the
Pirates maybe it could have been
really yeah incredible well kind of
Opera
that's exactly what it is literally
gonna rock into I Will Survive
Lulu is a superstar well listen I wish
you both thank you very much I know it's
been a very long few months right life a
life facing a few months but yep yes
set myself on the back thank you darling
it's lovely to talk to you great to see
you looking so well thank you
[Music]